new economic data paint a grim picture
of March as the country came to a
standstill business executives tell
President Trump that a key component to
reopening the economy is a lot more
testing the governor of New York says
he's signing an executive order that
will require people to wear a face
covering in public I'm Shelby Holliday
and here are your coronavirus headlines
from The Wall Street Journal u.s.
industrial production fell five point
four percent in March
it's the biggest drop in measured
factory utility and mining production
since nineteen forty two retail sales
which include a measure of purchases at
stores bars and restaurants fell eight
point seven percent in March from a
month earlier it's the biggest
month-over-month drop since records
began in 1992 these historic lows are
the result of the pandemic affecting
factories malls restaurants and other
businesses weekly jobless numbers will
be released today and the number of
Americans seeking unemployment benefits
is expected to surpass 20 million
business leaders told President Trump
that his administration must
dramatically ramp up coronavirus testing
according to people familiar with the
matter the executives said that tests
were necessary to make Americans feel
confident enough to resume their normal
lives a White House spokesman declined
to comment on the conversation Trump
recently announced that executives from
companies like General Motors Apple and
McDonald's are all part of a new task
force to reopen the economy the
president is set to release new
guidelines today about restarting the
country by first opening up states with
the least coronavirus cases it will
ultimately be up to governor's to decide
when to open their states all people in
public must have a mass in the
hardest-hit u.s. state New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo announced a new facemask
rule that will kick in Friday people
will be required to wear face coverings
in public settings where they can come
into contact with others like in grocery
stores or when using public
transportation
coverings include medical masks as well
as bandanas or scarves Cuomo said there
could eventually be penalties for people
who don't comply with the order